alone what do you carries he's a loser
he's my friend now when we first meet
your character Andrew he seems like the
typical high school jock but the good
thing about love Victor is have the time
to really get to know all these
characters really kind of peel back
those layers so how would you describe
Andrew at the beginning of the series
versus who he is at the end well let me
tell you right now I was nothing like
Andrew in high school I was more close
to my comic books and video games and I
certainly was and when it came to
portraying the antithesis of what I was
in high school especially you know the
project I worked on a lot of you look
smart was another look into that
opposite of my experience what Andrews
sort of does at least in my mind is
maybe they don't consider what they're
doing as being a bully action maybe
they're not fully aware especially at
the age of sixteen seventeen there's no
way you could be fully cognizant to the
repercussions for your doing but Andrew
of course the season learns that his you
know dynamic with Victor and what he
thinks to be just joking around and just
messing around ultimately carries much
more weight than he's willing to in the
beginning listens and admits or come to
terms with but that's again that's
growing up that's what being young is
it's not necessarily having the
foresight to see what your actions do to
others and learning without lessons
refine your senses I suppose so one of
the most gut-wrenching moments of love
Simon was when he was outed in front of
the entire school
out his consent and in the end of love
Victor Andrew could have had that
opportunity to out him to win me a back
from Victor are you can tell everyone no
I would never do that that was such an
amazing moment what was that like for
you reading that in the script Andrew
had the opportunity to out you know
Victor and basically derail his life in
his own journey of self-discovery but I
think what makes
Andrew so unique in you know I guess
bully landscape he's reinventing
bullying I suppose and clearly he was
able to transfix this on to Victor and
was like I would never
that's your fingers crossed for season
two what would you like to see moving
forward especially for Andrew oh good
well I mean in general help keep
incorporating and sort of continue the
lady foundation for different groups
getting brought to the forefront and
having their voices be heard
specifically for Android selflessly I
just want to be brought into that friend
group I want to be friends with Felix oh
and we friends look like although in the
way things ended season one that's not
looking too good for that but you never
know it's just heartbreaking to watch
them film those scenes together and have
so much fun and then Andrew scenes from
like alone playing basketball with my
friends I feel like acting is in your
blood your dad is Academy Award winner
Cuba Gooding jr. did you always kind of
just want to be like okay dad I'm gonna
follow in your footsteps see it's
interesting to have that perspective of
seeing where he went of his career and
how that relates to where my career is
going and we would have talks especially
as we as I got older and I sort of
realized that act and he's like a viable
option something that really was
passionate about that he would basically
tell me well son you have to remember
and this industry predicts it's all it
come it comes and it goes things are up
things are down and you have to remain
in steadfast in your decision to be true
to yourself and find that truth as an
actor I'm luckily you know blessed to
have him in my life to if something
needs answering if I have that question
I'm very perfect and you know it's funny
I have friends and people who are
you know attribute you know who my
father is and how it relates to me being
working and I'm like that you're
absolutely right I would be an idiot if
not able to see how and work that he's
done paid the foundation from what I am
able to do to tie it back into love
victory in and of itself is really the
story that I think people gravitate
towards the idea that past generations
have laid a groundwork and a foundation
to allow you know current generations or
future generations to succeed off of
their backs decades ago you struggle to
find one Latino latina actor in any
landscape and now they're forefront of a
huge series it's mind-blowing but it's
also incredibly inspired and I think
that's sort of the relationship I have
with my father I love my mom parents
upon watching the show I didn't realize
that that was your dad and I just fell
in love with your performance and then
everything that was like kind of just a
cool cherry on top like they find out
that you're the son of Cuba Gooding jr.
like what's the first thing they ask you
well they always ask me what it's like
to have someone sort of in that
stratosphere where their presence online
and to other people is maybe different
to how I proceed from this my father for
me growing up it was like oh this the
actor father and the Nerds the father
father and he I commend him immensely
and again for my mother for being able
to balance the Hollywood lifestyle what
he did for his job and also being there
as a father and taking me to baseball
games and you know supporting me I did
comedy sports he was at every match even
though I'm horribly unfunny okay he
certainly certainly made his presence
known that's what parenting is just
showing up just paying attention and
that was like the most touching thing I
think especially now that I'm an adult
and I'm sure you're just like chatting
with your friends you're like no my dad
is not yelling show me the money show me
show me the money especially when Rhett
was just
you're like dad I booked a new job he's
like show me show me the money do you
have a favorite role that he's ever
played rod Tidwell Jim Weider is so
prolific you know obviously when you're
young girls wanna watch Jerry Maguire I
can't say Oh throughout time or my life
that was my favorite my favorite was
snow dogs to be quite honest I thought
that was stuff it touched me as a kid
knows like oh this is a level of
entertainment you can achieve with the
story especially because of how much I
love dogs it creates this landscape for
kids to sort of get into hack them in
performance and at least for me and then
as I got older you know trained and boys
in the hood is the obviously it's so
much fun to watch an actor later on the
issues of what becomes their career and
then I saw him in Chicago on Broadway
I'm watching him kind of come full
circle as this you know season wise
lawyer character it was like he played
Billy Flynn he'd be very mad if I forgot
the name and and it was just so
interesting to see him both is the son
and also as just an actor learning the
craft to watch how a career can
transform and become what it you know
inevitably obviously is still working
he's directing now he's great at it so
it's like might as well just keep giving
him kudos while he while he keeps
learning it I'm so excited for fans to
get to know you more see you're acting
more do you have any dream roles you
mentioned that when you were in high
school you loved comic books is there a
superhero you love to play oh absolutely
I mean we never know but I guess growing
up the second I introduced montaner down
on me from there when they introduced
Miles Morales and black spider-man
character I was like this is so true to
me and like the idea of what it means to
push yourself to fit in and do the right
thing you know even when things are
ignite would obviously be immensely
grateful to even have the opportunity to
try and portray that but I also
understand Hollywood is fickle so
anything I could dress up and let go
half that moment is just books items so
superhero would be awesome
welcome to a scary movie just because I
love scary movies so much personally but
you know some fun something that can
gravitate towards like a large audience
and we'll see
[Music]